dans les années 50 un repas prêts à
manger ça ressemblait à sucy 70 ans plus
tard c'est ceci d'après s'il fait que la
recette soit bien identifiée qu'on a eu
la liste d'ingrédients aussi complète
sur l'étiquette
isabelle marquis à analyser l'offre
abondante de repas dit santé de six
compagnies offrant du prêt-à-manger en
formule boîte hebdo livrés à domicile
fit gastronomie isabelle huot tout cuit
week aux saveurs santé et créa loach
chacune des six compagnies nous offre un
bel éventail de mai dans les valeurs
nutritives sont très intéressantes
ils peuvent être fort en sortant fait
qu'on peut vraiment qualifier c'est le
lot de repas souris et les processus
pour observer et goûter certains plats
on a fait appel au chef jonathan la
pierre dre iam de l'ithq
alors qu'est ce qu'on mange m aux bonnes
questions vraiment l'air d'être plus
industrielles comme procédé de
fabrication
il y avait quelques blocs étaient
évidemment très industrialisé mais on a
quelques uns qui se rapprochait d'un co
maison d'apparaître devant les écarts
assez marqués sur le côté qualité goût
ce que personnellement je me serais un
peu moins depuis
évidemment ils n'ont pas mangé la
cinquantaine de plats comme ab mais dans
ce que jonathan a goûté trois compagnies
se sont démarqués
ça va créer à lunch fit gastronomie et
oui cook
ces deux dernière offrant des repas
réfrigérée et non congelés camp nou là
on ouvrait la salle de sports oms a le
goût du dr etienne plourde et co
fondateur de wikio une entreprise née en
2013 qui compte aujourd'hui près de 400
employés
quand on a démarré le seul marché
existait c'était du congé justement nous
déjà l'art avec du frais c'est une façon
de se démarquer la réalité au final ce
que c'est difficile d'arriver à avoir un
aussi bon de report qui a été congelé
qu'un repos qui est resté frais et même
un petit côté aussi marketing alias ça
se présente mieux c'est plus beau c'est
vraiment important pour nous regarder
des blu artisanaux donc ça fait vraiment
partie de l'adn de la compagnie ont
demandé de placer les commandes
comment ça a été cette expérience là ça
c'est bien fait mais je voudrais dire
que ça a été plus compliqué surtout
beaucoup plus long que ce à quoi je
m'attendais ça faisait beaucoup de mes à
regarder et parmi lesquels sélectionné
aussi puisqu'un autre de nos critères
était d'avoir une offre santé ou du
moins dit santé nous on a un petit peu
plus positionner notre prof comme la
meilleure de pro à personne dit le
rapport ça fait que peu importe la
définition de santé tu peux un peu
personnalisé d'europe à ta façon
la définition de santé de chaque
entreprise est complètement différente
je vais prendre l'exemple d'isabelle
vote c'est clair net précis et les
critères sont essentiellement des
critères nutritionnels en quantité de
calories de sodium protéines lipides
glucides effet bon quand on pense charpy
tout de suite je voyais arriver le tofu
en coureur ce qu'on avait des plats
merveilleux de te fut que je consommais
tous les jours qu'on a dû retirer parce
qu'ils ont des pauvres suffisamment ton
que là on a misé sur les 32 meilleurs
vendeurs qui ce qu'on enlevait est
malheureusement là dans la plupart des
causes cd v gt
on constate en effet que très peu de
plats végétariens sont offertes par les
différentes compagnies et en os mais en
proportion dans les boîtes de façon
générale on a un choix de choix rarement
plus que ça qu'on se dit on offre des
aliments santé c'est toujours la crainte
banc mais ça va être fade ça sera pas
bon qu'on a travaillé fort avec les
chefs pour avoir un repas congelés avec
une belle liste d'ingrédients aussi à
quel point la consommation d'aliments
prêts à manger c'est une source de
sodium dans notre alimentation
mais d'offrir un report qui a pas trop
s'est elle pas trop de sodium
c'est ma mission pour offrir des plats
faibles en sodium en sucre ou en
matières grasses
isabelle a dû parfois faire des
compromis comme ce poulet général tao
sans panure pour vrai je serai jamais
peas aixois général tôt le goût est
quand même intéressant
certaines compagnies offrent des repas
pour des personnes qui veulent perdre du
poids comme ici le plan minceur de
saveurs santé l'écart il est coco et ses
patates nos plaines qui est exact c'est
tout qui ont la plus grande offre le
seul critère clairement exposé c'est que
chacun des plats compte y ait moins de
500 calories mais ils sont même pour
plusieurs en bottes 300 c'est trop peu
même pour quelqu'un qui est en mode
perte de poids danse c'est bien mais on
a quand même un certain nombre de mes
qui sont probablement transformé avec
beaucoup plus d'additifs c'est quand
même assez savoureux bienvenus
[Musique]
même si aucune compagnie n'a obtenu la
note parfaite le choix d'isabelle s'est
arrêté sur deux créé à lunch comme
jonathan ainsi que tout cuit la boîte
qu'on a commandée c'est ce qu'ils
appellent leur coffret santé donc qui
est supposé regrouper l'ensemble des
mecs qui contiennent moins de sodium et
des valeurs nutritives général qui ont
été revus par une technicienne en
diététique qui travaillent avec eux
l'offre de tous puis est vraiment la
cuisine traditionnelle québécoise
réconfortante toute simple de conscience
et que pas au bout des pistes non pas
aux autres compagnies voulait des mille
et une nuits j'ai beaucoup aimé ce que
fait créer leur petite entreprise de
montréal qui travaille vraiment comme
travaillant dans un service traiteur
cuisine très créative cette fois qu'une
recherche de cette liste un peu de thé
sur les couleurs la purée la façon que
c'est dressé on a l'impression d'un mais
qui était vraiment fait maison
c'est bon goût la peine ça va deux de
ces compagnies ne vendent que par
abonnement
ce que j'ai trouvé un peu dommage voire
même agaçant dans une certaine mesure
c'est que nous ramène toujours à la
proposition de s'abonner les principes
d'abonnement où l'on me nourrit pour la
semaine au complet c'est pas pour moi
cela dit dépannage faire changement
oui définitivement des offres là dedans
qui sont intéressantes
ce qui est intéressant c'est que dans ce
cas ci contrairement à l'oeuvre de resto
c'est qu'on a la composition complète on
sait ce qu'on mange dans notre
échantillonnage les prix des places
varie selon les compagnies de neuf dans
50 à 12 dollars 5 ans
dans des barquettes aussi compostage et
belle surprise les repas arrive tous
dans des plats compostables recyclables
ou biodégradables ya possibilité avec ce
qui sur la marché en ce moment de bien
se nourrir mais ma gare dont ceux de
grasse comme étant une belle option pour
se donner congé de cuisine de temps en
temps mais peut-être pas pour remplacer
complètement ce qu'on mange à l'habitude
[Musique]